Sonic the Hedgehog is a family-friendly movie,
but there are a few things in it that'll leave
older viewers scratching their heads.
Much like Sonic himself, the movie zips by
pretty quickly.
Here are the things we saw that only adults
would have noticed.
Tom Wachowski, by all measures, is a good
person.
Sure, he's a police officer who breaks the
law and ends up being hunted by the public
as a terrorist, but he does it all to save
his new friend Sonic.
That apparent selflessness doesn't stop Rachel,
the sister of Tom's wife Maddie, from hating
everything about him.
Of course, Tom eventually becomes a fugitive
and Rachel gets tied up for good measure,
finally giving her a clear reason to dislike
Tom, but Rachel wasn't a fan long before all
that.
Rachel even goes as far as suggesting Tom
and Maddie get a divorce.
Maybe Tom did something offscreen, or in a
deleted scene, but from what we can tell,
he's a good husband, loves his wife, wants
to save people, and appears to be the most
helpful person in Green Hills.
Rachel and Maddie also seem to have a good
relationship, making Rachel's hate for Tom
even more unjustified.
"It's all about family, Tom."
Doctor Ivo "Eggman" Robotnik wants to catch
Sonic so he can study the extraterrestrial
blue hedgehog and his powers.
However, this plan is misguided from the beginning,
as Dr. Robotnik consistently shoots to kill.
When Dr. Robotnik and Sonic first meet at
Tom's house, Robotnik sends his mad scientist
drones after Sonic, guns blazing.
It's hard to not wonder why someone who wants
to study a being would try to kill it first.
"Dead or alive" is a common phrase bad guys
use in movies, but in this case, it's more
beneficial for Dr. Robotnik to keep Sonic
alive.
Later in the movie, Dr. Robotnik discovers
one of Sonic's quills, studies its powers,
and uses the quill to make his ship and drone
army stronger.
Clearly, there are benefits to not shooting
first and asking questions later - for a guy
who's supposed to be the smartest asset at
the U.S. military's disposal, Robotnik is
awfully slow on the uptake.
"Sorry, Major, what was your name?"
".Benning"
"Nobody cares."
During Sonic the Hedgehog, Tom doesn't just
become a wanted fugitive.
He's deemed a full-blown, dangerous terrorist
- yet when Dr. Robotnik magically disappears,
he's apparently able to go right back to his
normal life.
Green Hills clearly isn't a major city, which
would seem to make it incredibly difficult
for Tom to even show his face outside the
house, but once the government decides all's
well that ends well, his fellow citizens seem
to agree.
Even if Tom were somehow able to offer the
entire world proof of his innocence, there's
no way life would return to normal that quickly.
In the real world, people tend to attach negative
connotations to those accused of major crimes
whether or not they're eventually convicted.
Tom's career in law enforcement would seem
to be yet another complicating factor - what
kind of small-town cop would get to go back
on patrol right after getting himself mixed
up in something like this?
"What am I doing."
Sonic the Hedgehog is a fairly light-hearted
movie - but there's no getting around the
fact that Sonic himself causes a lot of destruction.
His base-running shenanigans cause the widespread
power outage that sets the events of the movie's
plot in motion.
As a result, businesses and residents lose
their power and the government and military
have to step in.
Those types of resources cost a lot of money.
While it's Dr. Robotnik's fault for shooting
up the streets with his drones and ship, none
of it would have happened if Sonic hadn't
been rather careless with his powers in the
first place.
It's entertaining to watch Sonic dodge the
mustache-wearing Dr. Robotnik, but for the
adults in the audience, it's hard not to wonder
who's going to pay for all the cleanup and
repair when it's all over.
Sonic is cool, lives on his own terms, is
a bit edgy and partly corny - in short, he's
a big-screen character created within the
cultural template of a Gen-Zer.
Of course, he's still a blue hedgehog who
shouldn't really have any interest in or reference
point to pop culture, but the filmmakers had
a vested interest in making Sonic as relatable
as possible to the audience while being funny
for the whole family.
What better way to make sure he can relate
to the kids in the crowd?
Of course, millennials are also part of the
target demographic, since the first Sonic
video game was released in 1991.
Sonic's dear friend Tom is more culturally
in line with older audience members, even
though everyone can appreciate a good dad
joke.
Sonic's unintentional show of power - and
the massive power outage that resulted - led
to the government and military stepping in
by hiring the clearly insane Dr. Robotnik
to figure out what happened.
Although Sonic the Hedgehog is meant to be
a light-hearted movie that the entire family
can enjoy, if an extraterrestrial blue hedgehog
suddenly appeared in real life and seemed
to pose some sort of threat, every branch
of the military would be involved.
There's no way the government would trust
a single mad scientist to do the job.
"Buh buh blah duh duh blah duh duh blah."
Jim Carrey's mugging, scene-stealing antics
are one of the best parts of the movie, but
they also might be the most unbelievable.
Given that this is about a super-fast alien
hedgehog who can talk, that's really saying
something.
Dr. Robotnik is the type of person who has
to state his accomplishments out loud even
when no one's asking.
He's clearly an accomplished individual, so
much so that the government tasks him with
determining why the lights went out.
Through this behavior, it's clear that he
has to prove he's better than everyone else
and he points out the shortcomings of others
simply because they took a different path.
This is because people like Dr. Robotnik are
insecure, possibly because he had a painful
childhood.
He mentions to Tom that the only other person
who punched him in the face was a bully when
he was younger, which may have led to him
being the way he is.
On the surface, he's an accomplished villain
who makes the audience laugh with a touch
of Jim Carrey goofiness and quirks, but deep
down he's insecure and deals with his insecurity
by cutting others down - or blasting them
to bits with his drone army.
While the government rewarding Tom with a
$50 Olive Garden gift card is meant to be
funny, it's also an absolutely terrible way
to say "Thanks for saving the world."
Most sane adults wouldn't be content with
receiving any kind of gift card - at any amount
- for what Tom and his family went through.
The government, at the very least, should
be concerned about Dr. Robotnik, their main
asset.
What happened is a big deal and deserves answers,
yet the world seems content with simply forgetting
anything ever happened and moving on.
Sonic and the Wachowskis deserve a happy ending,
and it's a sweet, funny way of concluding
this feel-good tale, but for anyone with a
job and a mortgage, Sonic the Hedgehog's conclusion
will make absolutely no sense.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.